the partial government shutdown is now
three days old and Congress is not
expected to end it in 2018 that means
many facilities at national parks are
closed to tourists during this big
vacation week and about 800,000 federal
workers will soon not be paid chip Reid
should be traveling with the president
in Florida instead he's at the White
House chip good morning
well good morning that's right the
president was supposed to spend
Christmas at his mar-a-lago estate in
Florida instead he and the first lady
will be spending it here at the White
House and White House officials say this
shutdown could last into the new year
it's very possible that this shutdown
will go beyond the 28th and into the new
Congress towards two nights before
Christmas and all through the House and
Senate not a creature was stirring the
bill right now is in the Senate the ball
is in the Senate's court most members of
Congress left the Capitol till Thursday
they'll get paid but the 380,000
furloughed federal workers will not try
to prepare for but it's hard to prepare
for something like this so try doing
best you can at the White House calls to
the switchboard went nowhere
we apologize but due to the lapse in
federal funding we are unable to take
your call the government funded these
barriers and these even the National
Christmas tree was closed I don't know
between the two sides the roadblock that
other barrier the wall on the Mexican
border the president's not going to not
accept money for a border wall but the
president may be back on the fence his
acting chief of staff said the president
would agree to less than a concrete wall
and instead President Trump tweeted a
photo of a barricade made of steel slats
President Trump if you want to open the
government you must abandon the wall
Democrats offered the president only 1.3
billion dollars for border security less
than their last offer of 1.6 billion
there is frankly no path towards his
getting five billion dollars in American
taxpayer money to meet his campaign
promise of a big beautiful wall so until
they reached some kind of compromise and
end this partial government shutdown
federal
workers who are deemed essential will
have to keep working without getting
paid Dana a rough Christmas for a lot of
those people chip thank you